what I would understand to be a filter
is perhaps slightly different from what
people who use Instagram would describe
as a filter usually in an app or cam
phone app or Facebook or some other
thing where you can apply some filter
it's going to actually be a combination
of lots of low level processing of
various types you know blurs contrast
changes color changes what I tend to use
in my day-to-day work would be below
level things Gaussian blurs edge
detection this kind of stuff but really
they're all filters and they all take
some image process it and come come up
with some output today we're going to
look at a simple technique called kernel
convolution and that is kind of the core
of Gaussian blurs and nor mean blurs and
edge detection and lots of other things
and it's a very simple technique that we
use a lot around here with computer
vision work kernel convolution is just a
process where we take a small grid of
numbers and we pass them over the whole
image transforming it based on what
those numbers are and by using different
numbers in the kernel we can perform
blurs or edge detection or sharpen
unsharp and basically any effect we like
so I'll first describe kernel
convolution and then we'll look at a
couple of examples of what sort of
kernels that we see a lot of kernel
convolution works by if this is our test
image that's five by five and this is
our kernel which is three by three so
generally speaking the kernel will be
smaller than the image and usually
actually quite small and what we do this
is my moveable kernel that we've come up
with and what we do basically is for
every pixel in our image we put our
kernel over it so that the pixel is in
the center so let's look at this pixel
here number 64 we put our kernel over it
and then we are looking at the three by
three grid centered around that pixel
and we take whatever values in our
kernel multiply it by 17 and then the
top value and multiply it by 14 on the
top corner value of x 13 so we take each
corresponding image value and kernel
value we multiply them together in pairs
and then we sum the whole thing up and
then finally we normalize by dividing by
the total value of our kernel to make
sure that it doesn't get brighter or
darker so severe like averaging
it's exactly is averaging yep in a way
it's just a big weighted average or if
all the numbers are the same an actual
average so in fact that's the first one
we can look at so if if all of our
values in our Kohinoor won then that's a
mean blur so if you go into Adobe
Photoshop or any other image protein
package and you go for blurs blur
filters and mean that's what it's going
to be doing this is a kernel of size 3
you usually will do it obviously
centered around a single pixel so odd
sizes so 3 5 7 and so on so what we're
going to do here is we're going to go 17
x 1 + 14 x 1 and so on and divide the
whole thing by the sum of this which is
9 and that will basically take an
average and then we'll overwrite that
pixel with the output of that kernel
convolution the only thing to make clear
is that we should output these to a
different image because if we overwrite
them as we go it's going to mess up the
mat as we go down I use blurs to remove
noise from images before I process them
in other ways for my job some other
people might try and remove noise from
images just to make them look better or
you might try and blow the background
out in a photograph or something like
that and you can achieve a lot of
effects just by convolving
a kernel over an image you move it
around for every pixel and when you look
at whatever window but it's the size of
your kernel the only other thing is but
if you're at the edge then you've got to
make some decision as to what you do
here so you could ignore those ones and
they wouldn't contribute at all or you
could wrap the image around or you could
duplicate the edge ones you could do
lots of different things generally
speaking I would just ignore them and
then do a slightly smaller averaging for
the corners that'll mean but the
blurring around the edges is ever so
slightly less than the blurring
elsewhere in the image but just in the
last edge pixel in a five to ten
megapixel image probably won't make much
of a difference so that's a very very
simple kernel if we go for a slightly
more complicated cone or we can go for
the normal distribution of Gaussian blur
so gaussian blur is extremely common
probably I suppose the most common blur
it's a little bit more controlled and
edge preserving than a mean blur and so
a lot of people like it so a normal
distribution is a bell curve so if we
have our axes there and we draw a bell
curve and the standard deviation of this
curve so the standard deviation is
essentially the average distance from
the mean of all the points will
determine how
why inves bell-curve is so a really
large standard deviation we'll have a
really large bell curve okay it should
be symmetrical and a really small
standard deviation we'll have a really
tight bell curve which is essentially
really prioritizing the the weights in
the middle now if we wait these numbers
based on the values from our normal
distribution then we get a gaussian
blur' an example of a very small
Gaussian kernel would be a 3x3 so these
values are going to be you know floating
point decimal values but we just
simplify it a little bit so for two on
the edges and one now the crucial
difference between this and the mean
blur is that we're really prioritizing
those in the middle the further away you
get from the pixel of interest the less
weight you have in the combined average
and that's important because it
basically means that you're not going to
be blowing too much where where there's
an edge let's say a sharp change in
intensity as you approach that edge
you're not going to be taking too many
of those pixels and this Gaussian blur
can obviously get a lot bigger so in
your image processing program you might
have an option that says standard
deviation or ladys and what that's
really referring to is a standard
deviation of the normal distribution but
produced this kernel and also the width
of the kernel so we have to increase the
size of our kernel as the radius of the
Gaussian function increases this is a
very small normal distribution if this
was a bell curve it's it's really steep
if we had a bigger standard deviation
then we're going to need a bigger window
to be able to hold enough information
this isn't near big enough so let me
draw a test image and then we'll do a
blow on it and see how it works so okay
so this is a good sized image this image
is pretty basic it's an edge so we've
got area of 50 intensity and layer of
100 intensity just put our mean one here
as well just for comparison so if we do
I mean first so we put that on let's say
this this 50 here which is all right on
the edge okay so we put our kernel on
there and we're going to be doing 50
times 1 plus 50 times 1 plus it 100
times 1 and so on so it's going to be
100 200 300 400 5 600 and then we divide
that by 9 and that gives us 66.6 okay
and we round it to the nearest integer
value for a Gaussian blur with this
Gaussian blur here we're going to be
doing 50 times 1 plus
two times two plus 100 times one and so
on okay and that will be a value of this
is where we cut a hair so it's a
thousand these add up to a thousand
divided by sixteen which is sixty two
and a half so ever so slightly closer to
these fifty values on this edge then
perhaps the mean blow was it's subtle
but the the edge has been slightly
preserved and generally speaking we're
giving more weight to the numbers really
really close to us these are very
low-level filters these are sort of
filters I will use in my day day to day
work to alter images fine but I need to
analyze but on Facebook and you know on
the all these camera apps for your phone
you'll see a lot of other perhaps more
complicated filters bloom you know sepia
vintage ones that make it look like some
camera from the 1800's or something like
that and really what they're doing is
nothing hugely complicated they're just
chaining together low-level image
processing so a grayscale filter maybe a
bit of blur and then some kind of border
to make you look good in things like
this so really these kind of filters at
the core of a lot of the stuff that you
see even if you might not know it
you